[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace muchos años cuando empezado la
carrera de biología me enteré de una de
las cosas más interesantes que teníamos
en bolivia un delfín de río para mí fue
un shock porque un delfín en un país
mediterráneo donde estamos al centro de
sudamérica debe ser como que una cosa
bien importante y todo el mundo debe
saber entonces empecé a preguntar a la
gente alrededor sabes que existen los
delfines de río en bolivia y la
respuesta siempre era negativa alguno
que otros decía sí creo que hay en el
beni lo llama bufeo y todos entonces
como que me pareció increíble empecé a
buscar y me doy cuenta que el único
trabajo científico que se había
realizado sobre esta especie era en 1969
por un suizo entonces es decir no
sabíamos nada sobre esta especie en ese
momento decidió empezar a estudiar
empezar a investigar y conocer más sobre
la vida de este animal tan tan increíble
y a medida que iban estudiando y
aprendiendo sobre el animal me di cuenta
cosas bien interesantes una de las
primeras cosas es
color rosado no vive adaptado todo el
cuerpo para vivir en este medio acuático
en ríos y lagunas desde nuestro
territorio es es increíble entonces
seguía investigando y luego surgen otras
preguntas no dices esa esa apariencia
tan peculiar un hocico largo como puede
conseguir su alimento en estos ríos que
es totalmente oscuro seguramente él va y
busca como con palitos de dientes y
logra conseguir su alimentación entonces
empezaron a surgir más y más preguntas
otra de las cosas muy muy fascinantes
era que es lo que pasa con ese animal de
repente tiene una una frente muy
abultada que se llama melón y eso le
sirve para moverse y tiene un sistema de
comunicación como un radar por ejemplo
que para que le permite meterse entre
los bosques inundados empezar a nadar
por ahí y comunicarse no la madre y la
cría cómo es posible que una madre y la
cría pueda comunicarse en esas aguas tan
turbias y empiezan a surgir más y más
preguntas fascinantes y la gente por
suerte a lo largo del tiempo ha empezado
a darse
cuenta que teníamos esta esta maravilla
y es así que el buceo ha sido declarado
por ejemplo patrimonio nacional de
bolivia en 2008 posteriormente ha sido
declarado patrimonio departamental del
departamento del beni y también de parte
de patrimonio
como símbolo de la ciudad de trinidad
entonces uno dice puig a este animal
tiene tanta
tanto título de sant patrimonial debe
ser uno de los animales más conocidos en
bolivia y debe ser uno de los más
protegidos sin embargo no las amenazas
que tiene esta especie es la misma que
está sufriendo toda nuestra fauna todas
nuestras amenazas y solamente voy a
resaltar algunas una de las amenazas más
terribles que tenemos es la
contaminación tanto de la basura
contaminación y destrucción del hábitat
el tema de la basura es tan recurrente y
escuchamos en las noticias salen en las
redes sociales como el plástico se está
convirtiendo en una amenaza a toda
nuestra fauna
tanto a aves como como mamíferos y si
efectivamente está esa foto es tomada en
uno de nuestros ríos en el río ibare
donde estudiamos y pueden ver la
cantidad de basura de plásticos donde la
gente utiliza es una amenaza muy grande
otra amenaza que tenemos con el buceo es
la más fuerte de las amenazas que es la
destrucción del hábitat miles y miles de
hectáreas en ese momento de bosque están
siendo transformados en unos cultivos
donde existe quemas y chaqueos ahora en
este mismo momento que estoy hablando
los bosques se están quemando no tenemos
hectáreas y hectáreas unos sobrevuela y
son nubes y nubes que estamos
destrozando nuestra biodiversidad y esto
indirectamente también queda y afecta a
los bufeos los afecta de qué forma que
empiezan a tener todos estos sistemas de
agroindustriales empiezan a verter
químicos pesticidas herbicidas a los
ríos a nuestros ríos todos estos
sistemas agroindustriales miles y miles
de hectáreas necesitan agua y empiezan a
desviar canales de río no para empezar a
a regar estos sistemas luego tenemos que
tienen herbicidas y plaguicidas
pesticidas que son arrojados
directamente a los campos al río mismo y
por otro lado
la gran cantidad de caminos que se hacen
se desvían para empezar a llegar a estas
zonas tan tan grandes en esta imagen
satelital que todos conocemos es en el
departamento de santa cruz podemos ver
que el 2011 más o menos se pueden ver
las áreas verdes eran bosques imagínense
todo el bosque y las líneas más blancas
son zonas con cultivos actualmente
y podemos ver que todavía quedaban o
unos años más tarde esto ha crecido ha
aumentado de una forma muy muy dramática
y vemos que se ha perdido mucho bosque y
finalmente está la siguiente imagen del
2017 vemos que esto ha crecido mucho más
no sé en qué estado están lo que no ha
querido ver más pero se dan cuenta
estamos perdiendo nuestros bosques a
unas tasas alarmantes estamos perdiendo
recursos hídricos y esto afecta
terriblemente al delfín del río otra de
las amenazas que tiene por ejemplo es
que muchos de estos animales quedan
atrapados en las redes de pescadores
donde generalmente las crías y juveniles
van a morir
porque no saben cómo escapar no tienen
la experiencia suficiente o a veces los
pescados
ayudan o bien llegan muy tarde y no no
pueden colaborar los entonces
lastimosamente fallecen y es una tasa
alta de mortalidad otra amenaza también
es que en algunos casos muy raros la
gente está empezando a matarlos para
utilizarlos como carnada a los
pescadores de la zona entonces todas
estas amenazas que estamos viendo nos
hacen nos hacen pensar que qué es lo que
pasa porque la especie está tan
vulnerable que es lo que de repente
sucede y encima tenemos otra nueva
amenaza que son los efectos del cambio
climático que no sabemos realmente cómo
va bueno hay modelos que nos muestran
que en el amazonas va a ser muy muy
negativo digamos pero tenemos sequías y
demás entonces tanta amenaza nos hace
preguntar qué podemos hacer qué
alternativas podemos dar para de
conservación para esta especie entonces
cómo venimos trabajando tantos años con
mi equipo hemos hemos empezado a ver y
una de estas alternativas en la que hoy
quiero hablar justamente
el ecoturismo y las buenas prácticas es
un turismo responsable entonces qué es
lo que nosotros estamos promoviendo con
el turismo responsable es que las
especies y las empresas que están
vinculadas empiecen a trabajar con este
tema
entonces qué es lo que buscamos como les
decía hay un constante conflicto entre
las poblaciones y los bufeos porque como
les explicaba quedan en las redes
algunos pescadores creen que son
competencia por eso entonces tenemos que
mitigar y una de las formas en estas dos
áreas era justamente el turismo para
esto hemos ubicado dos áreas de bolivia
que son bien interesantes que es una el
área protegida municipal municipal ibare
mamoré y el área pampas del yacuma las
dos en el beni porque la mayor cantidad
de población del buceo están en estos
ríos y en ese departamento lo que
queremos hacer y hemos empezado a
trabajar hace algunos años es primero
reunirnos con las autoridades y hemos
diseñado una serie de actividades y
materiales con los cuales podemos
empezar a trabajar con los pescadores
nos hemos creado un
un libro por ejemplo es justamente para
las buenas prácticas de la observación
dvd bufeos en la cual damos como
directrices se ha trabajado también con
otros materiales y se está trabajando
con autoridades con con gente vinculada
al turismo
entonces qué es lo que decía uno de los
puntos focales es brindar alternativas
económicas y entre esas alternativas
económicas tenemos que es generar
ingresos para los pobladores de la zona
y estos ingresos pueden ser directos no
los directos son cuando llega el turista
se aloja en un hotel agarran toman un
tour por la zona o bien los y los
beneficios indirectos que son la señora
que va a vender el refresco por ahí el
taxista que lleva desde el aeropuerto
hasta hasta el hotel entonces todo esto
se va va va creando un interés en la
gente y se da cuenta que los digamos los
bufeos si les podrían dar un beneficio
económico y todo esto siempre bajo la
filosofía de que tienen que ser o estar
dentro de la filosofía de observación de
fútbol y esta filosofía es que sea un
uso no letal
no queremos promover cacería ni nada de
eso con el animal que sea un uso
sostenible que esto pueda generar la
oportunidad de que futuras generaciones
puedan verlos
y finalmente es que mi perturbación
mínima muchas veces en un área de ríos
en épocas secas se baja tanto el agua
que los delfines tienen que competir por
espacio con botes entonces todo esto
tenemos que tratar de deje de ordenarnos
y todo eso
qué es lo que buscamos estamos buscando
ordenar al turismo tener una área
turística donde los guías operadores la
gente que va trabajando con eso sea muy
muy responsable que te dé educación de
la naturaleza de primera calidad que la
gente sea capaz de distinguir las
amenazas reales sea capaz de ver un
buceo y evitar perturbar lo entonces
todo todo esto es un trabajo que
requiere educación principalmente
entonces qué es lo que promovemos
estamos promoviendo que un buffet o vivo
vale más que mil muertos y esto es
lógico ha habido un estudio en colombia
en el cual mostraban que en una
comunidad de pescadores un buffet o
muerto les daba de retribución entre 25
a 50 dólares al pescador porque mataba
lo feo y lograba conseguir esa cantidad
de peces como carnada sin embargo con
actividades de ecoturismo se ha visto
que a la zona empiezan a llegar miles y
cientos de miles de dólares justamente
por ver a una especie única
nosotros tenemos una especie única es
endémica de nuestro país y esa es la lo
mejor que podemos tener entonces qué es
lo que buscamos o sea yo les pido invito
a todos ustedes por ejemplo que que
conozcamos más del buffet o no nuestra
forma de actuar y de conservarlos a
estos animales pueden ser directamente
desde nuestra casa
podemos hacer acciones diferentes desde
ahora ustedes pueden ir aprender más de
la especie entender más sobre sus su
lugar de vida ir a conocer nuestras
maravillas que tenemos en esas áreas
protegidas entonces con y además en esa
forma ustedes están promoviendo la
observación de los bufeos
para contarles nosotros en estos 10 en
estos últimos años hemos creado mucho
material también hemos empezado a dar
charlas en las comunidades ribereñas a
los pobladores con autoridades como les
comentaba anteriormente en toda la gente
va aprendiendo y cuando tú lo va
aprendiendo le toma un poco más de
cariño lo mismo ha pasado con los
operadores de turismo hemos hecho
talleres en los cuales se les ha
enseñado el rol biológico de cada uno de
estos se les han mostrado que no es una
amenaza se les ha enseñado cosas que
nosotros también estamos en la
obligación de aprender y se ha generado
un compromiso y ellos están de acuerdo
en que tienen que apoyar y es parte de
nuestra riqueza también nosotros hemos
trabajado con niños
hemos creado material de niños y se les
está dando clases de charlas y todo eso
a los niños que viven en las comunidades
en a niños en áreas rurales porque estos
niños
son las futuras autoridades los que van
a tomar decisiones esos niños son los
futuros pescadores son los futuros guías
de turismo entonces tenemos que hacerles
recuperar lo que estamos perdiendo que
es ese ese ese amor por la naturaleza
también les pido a ustedes que empiecen
a aprender un poco más no es lo que más
es uno de los mensajes que les damos no
podemos hacer muchas de las actividades
si no es con la con el apoyo de ustedes
con su conocimiento y con esto
finalmente quiero contarles que lo que
buscamos en esta zona es que sean
certificadas a nivel internacional es
decir un turista a garry diga dónde hay
lugares donde puedo ver museos no hizo
un lugar donde hay buenas prácticas no
los matan donde es muy responsable
entonces queremos resaltar esta zona
queremos que bolivia salga nuevamente
con cosas positivas dentro de esto que
tanta amenaza tantos problemas que
tenemos a nivel ambiental cambie y se
muestre que somos un país muy muy
responsable
y para concluir los quiero quiero
recordarles no el buffet o es nuestro
patrimonio es un patrimonio nacional es
parte de nuestra herencia que estamos
dejando a las futuras generaciones
entonces es nuestra obligación como
bolivianos que empecemos a aprender
mucho más sobre la especie empecemos a
cuidarla y protegerla es nuestro
patrimonio y que mejor que un día de
aquí a las siguientes generaciones los
nietos los nietos de sus nietos
eventualmente tengan lo que tenemos
ahora el privilegio de vivir en un mundo
con con los delfines de río muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]